donald trump continues to hint at
running for the republican nomination
for president in 2024 he says the time
is coming he says we may have to do it
again he says i think you're going to be
very happy with what we decide but he
won't actually say it now there's a
bunch of different reasons speculative
reasons as to why he is not simply
announcing and the biggest one the most
con
the consensus is that it has to do with
financial reporting requirements and
that there would be additional scrutiny
on his completely scammy grifty
fundraising that he's doing if he
officially becomes a candidate that is
completely plausible
it also may be
that the rnc convinced him not to
announce before the midterms there was a
report a couple weeks ago the rnc told
trump if you announce that you're
running before the midterms we're not
going to pay your legal bills anymore
clearly the rnc thinks it would not be
good for them and for their candidates
running in november if trump announced
early